I tried to come up with the the Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep clever opener
I'm just drawing a blank
Phillip K dicks electric dreams this was
something that I had a pretty high level
of interest in as soon as I heard about
it and it's now it's now available on
Amazon I think it was available on
Amazon I places other than the US prior
to this maybe not even Amazon maybe I'm
not their services but it is now
available in the US on Amazon and I've
checked out what Amazon is telling me is
the first episode although if I look at
IMDB or Wikipedia it's more like the
sixth or eighth episode it's apparently
amazon has reordered them it's an
anthology show so I don't think it
actually matters but the one that I've
seen is called real life so I'm gonna
talk about this um while it's kind of
impossible to stay 100% spoiler free I'm
I'm gonna try really hard not to try and
ruin anything that happens later because
unlike my black mirror reviews where I
think I'm coming late to that party and
a lot of people already seen the stuff
this is brand-new stuff so I I don't
want to get into spoilers so much and
besides at least in terms of this first
one I think I can talk about you know
what the setup is and the broad-strokes
and not have to get into spoilers to
sort of give my thoughts on it so real
life is it's a take on virtual reality
and so you've got these these sort of
two parallel tracks you start out with
Anna Paquin in a let's say less gritty
blade runner-esque future um and she is
a cop who is basically suffering from
survivor's guilt there was a sort of
massacre of a whole bunch of cops that
she survived and there and then she and
her partner are still trying to find the
guy who did it but she's not dealing
with the stress of what she went through
very well and her wife because she is a
lesbian is a developer of you know
virtual reality and software and
software and things like that and
has her try out something that they're
about to roll out which is not
dissimilar from the ideas from Total
Recall which is it'll basically like
take a vacation from yourself go into
this virtual reality world experience
not only new places and new things but a
whole new life that is actually sort of
built around your subconscious and the
program sort of tries to interpret what
it thinks you want and so when she
starts using this she finds herself as
Terrence Howard in basically modern
times as we know them and he is you know
he is a billionaire software developer
whose wife was murdered and he's kind of
going on a bit of a vigilante hunt after
the guy who killed her but where things
start to get wobbly is in that world as
well he because he's a software
developer he has developed a headset
that starts a virtual reality thing and
so in that world
he's escaping the pain of losing his
wife by going to the world where he is a
cop in the and the slightly you know a
couple decades ahead future but in that
one he's yeah in that one she is turning
to this other world to escape from the
pain and the stress of her survivor's
guilt so the very natural question which
is exactly what you would expect this
and tackle is which one's actually real
and there's goods and bad points about
this and and one of the bad points is
kind of unavoidable which is that philip
k dick writings his works his concepts
have been mined by so many things for so
long not only the direct adaptations of
his work like Blade Runner like Total
Recall like a Scanner Darkly
but his his ideas and his concepts have
just permeated science fiction and they
are everywhere and unfortunately that
means when you when you go back to his
material and use
you don't going oh here's you know
here's a Philip P just dick concept
let's do something out of it it it's not
gonna feel especially fresh conceptually
um and not because they weren't original
ideas when he thought of them they were
but like I said all this stuff has been
ripped on and remixed by so many
different people filmmakers authors
comic book writers what have you in the
years since since he passed away so it's
not as original as you might hope you
know if I was gonna say depending on
what you expect I don't know what you
come into this expecting I mean I like
philip k dick stuff but you know i-i-i
guess what when you read his work it
feels slightly fresher I think cuz a lot
of us have seen an adapted mostly to
film and it's largely a visual aesthetic
and when you actually try and read his
writing that is kind of its own
experience but you know seeing it
translated into a visual medium like
this again it doesn't feel quite as
fresh but you know for the very core
premise of the anthology show I'm not
really sure there was a way around that
the other big weakness is some of the
writing now most of the long I'm not
gonna say most of the writing the
writing is when it's good it's good and
when it's not good it's bad and what I
mean is especially at the front end of
this thing the exposition explaining you
know where characters are the necessary
bullet points of their backstory and how
the technology that's being used
functions is delivered really really
clunky there are a handful of exposition
dumps either character history or
technical exposition dumps throughout
the episode and they never feel natural
it's it's one of those things that I it
makes me really appreciate that element
of black mirror that when they talk
about the technology they are able to
frame it in situations or maybe just you
know write dialogue or get actors who
are able to deliver it and not make it
sound like dial
they're able to you know mask it in a
sales pitch you know somebody you know
trying to talk somebody into buying this
technology or things like that and this
this doesn't do that quite as well so
the exposition is really really clunky
and as I said you know the whole fact
that it's gonna start messing you know
which is the real world what's it gonna
turn out to be is is not an unexpected
direction for it to go that being said
it does actually start to grab you as it
goes along and especially towards the
end I think a lot of that I would have
to chalk up to the performances that
they sort of engage with you on a level
that is actually a bit more than the
writing itself is inherently gonna
engage in and if I were to highlight an
MVP would probably be Terrence Howard
although you know Anna Paquin has some
good moments as well but the the moments
that I started getting absorbed into
this story was largely due to Terrence
Howard's performance and how well he was
able to convey some very complex
emotional beats of someone experiencing
pain and then starting to doubt whether
that pain is even real and it it is all
very interesting and layered and really
well delivered and the the way it ends
the the specifics of it some people may
see it coming some people may not see it
coming for me again maybe just because I
know too much sci-fi I kind of saw it
coming but it's still well delivered for
what it is so this wasn't exceptionally
strong but it was decent so I don't know
if I'm gonna stick with this thing for
the whole season I mean there's ten
episodes in this so it's a bigger
commitment then you know coming in to do
six episodes of Black Mirror was young
did starting with that fourth season of
that show so I I'm not gonna make a
promise that I'm gonna do all ten I'm
gonna do at least one more of this
because I want to try and get a sense if
what I just watch is one of the better
ones if it is just a you know a good
example of what I can expect if it is
I'll probably get through the first
season or is it you know does it get
better or is this as good as it gets and
all the other ones can't even measure up
to this if that's the case I may I may
not have more than one or two more in me
but we'll kind of see so far I'm looking
at that and going you've got potential
it's gonna come down to execution some
of the execution that this one was a bit
clunky but those are my thoughts on Phil
okay Dick's electric dreams real life
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it do all that stuff like and
subscribe and find me on Twitter so I
mean email if you want to support me on
patreon if you're feeling generous
all links for all that stuff is down
below and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]